- All right, now it's time
to close out that show
with something I hope will
add even more joy to your day.
This is What I'm Liking.
(audience cheering)
Well, Bella is clearly
her dad's little girl.
Now, I want you to meet another father,
who'd do anything to
make his daughter smile.
Seven year old, Bailey,
was devastated when she let
go of her brand new balloon.
It got stuck on the ceiling.
So, her dad sprung into action,
well, pretty much literally.
(heroic horns blowing)
(audience cheers)
Nice job.
We have James on the line right now.
Along with his wife Yui,
and two of their kids Bailey and Hazel.
Hi guys. How are ya? (laughs)
James nice moves there.
You're a real pro.
Are you an athlete?
- Yeah, so I saw the
look on my daughters face
whenever she lost the balloon,
and I was like man I
gotta get this balloon.
So, I was like let me see
if my legs still got it.
It's going back to my football,
basketball, and track days.
So, I tried to jump and grab it twice,
and I was just a little short.
So, I turned to my wife and I was like,
"Hey babe, take it and record this."
She had no idea what I
was getting ready to try.
So, I stepped back.
I wiped my shoes off to
make sure I had some grip
on the wall.
I ran and I jumped and
I was able to grab it.
- Well that was great. Pretty amazing.
Now, Bailey.
Bailey, let me ask.
What was it like when your
dad gave your balloon back?
That was pretty cool.
- It was the best thing
my daddy ever did for me,
and I was very surprised.
- That's the best thing daddy ever did.
All right, James.
Yui, Bailey, and Hazel.
I'm liking your post right now.
Thanks you guys. Nice job.
That's not all.
The show's season long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of Frixion,
the go to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show,
wants to celebrate those
creating fearlessly.
Just like you guys.
So, they're giving you $1,000.
There you go.
All right.
- Thank you!
- Thanks to all our guests this hour.
Anna Chlumsky, Cam, Anjelah Johnson-Reyes,
Christian, Lisa, Bella,
and Blessing Offor.
You can see a new season
of Jay Leno's Garage
in September on CNBC.
And check out local listing
to watch You Bet Your Life.
As Kelly says,
"Have a great day. If it's not change it."
Thanks everybody.